hi I'm Cameron from motion science and
if you're a motion designer who's
struggling to make your work look as
good as you know it can be then this
video is for you I created a program
called stylecraft that provides training
in the art of cinematic motion design
and also includes weekly feedback and
mentorship from me and industry leader
plus it comes with lifetime access to
the course so you can revisit it anytime
you need a refresher and finally you'll
have access to a private online
community of like-minded motion
designers here to help you break through
your plateau and grow your skill set
without having to do it alone
the reason I created this program is
because I know how frustrating it can be
when you're stuck at a certain level and
can't seem to make your work look any
better trust me I've been there but with
the right training and mentorship you
can overcome that hurdle and take your
work to the next level registration only
opens up a couple times a year and right
now it's open I currently have 500 happy
students who are seeing Real Results in
their work and I'd love to add you to
that list so if you're ready to break
through your plateau and start creating
better looking Pro level motion design
click the link below now